first I want to thank Bob and Mohammed
MIT for hosting this nice symposium and
also thank you for the nice introduction
indeed I'm the newest member of the
McGowan Institute as in she just said I
just went back to China about two months
ago September and it's a great honor to
share with you of my postdoctoral work
and ice tip of what I'm going to do for
my new lab so the title of my talk today
is visualizing
AMPA receptor or synaptic plasticity in
vivo so to this audience we will agree
that you know the human brain is the
most complex organ in the universe the
human brain our estimate consists of a
hundred billion neurons the neurons
connect with each other and so that they
can communicate with each other to this
audience I just briefly introduce that
you know but the neurons communicate
avicii data through a specialized area
called synapses so this figure
illustrate how the our neurons
communicate with each other basically
the signal comes from the presynaptic
side which are activated our presynaptic
neurons which will trigger the release
of the neurotransmitters the
neurotransmitters your trans transducers
across the synaptic cleft and then bond
to the postsynaptic receptors then the
binding or the personnel synaptic
receptors will trigger a series of
signaling cascade in such a way the
signal is transduced from the prison of
neuron to the postsynaptic neuron
so for the synapses actually the
formation and elimination of the
synapses and the efficacy of the
existing snaps is a very dynamic process
and can be modified by human experience
so this that dynamic process is called
synaptic plasticity and synaptic
plasticity play a very important role
for higher brain functions such as many
on a memory so in terms of synaptic
plasticity is less studies in the are
using electrophysiology measured and in
the especially at hippocampal acute
brain slices so as shown here here is a
recording electrode and on the other
side is a stimulation electrode so if
you record the baseline your
Yosi and the baseline is relatively
stable but but if you pair the recording
with a high frequency stimulation what
you can see is your detect a dramatic
increase in terms of epi see amplitude
indicating there is increase in the
synaptic strength while on the other
hand if you pair the recording with a
low frequency stimulation what happens
is your detect occurs in the EPS
amplitude or in other word you detect a
weakening of the synaptic connection as
you can see from both this diagram this
phenomena is called LTP or long-term
potentiation and this phenomena is
called Ltd long term depression so as
from the diagram you can see another
characteristic of LTP and Ltd is that
they are relatively long lasting in the
eye acute brain slicer studies can be as
stable as half an hour to an hour so
AMPA receptors is a major glutamate
receptors located on the postsynaptic
side so AMPA receptors media the
majority of the fast etc synaptic
transmission so here I'm showing you the
structure of the AMPA receptors which
are basically tetrahedra Marik structure
with 3 to 4 are transmembrane proteins
and based on the structure at the serum
detail it can be categorized into two
categories one is called a long to you
the other one is called short tio
I'll show here the serum until is really
an important forum her sub are
trafficking and a function since it has
a lot protein phosphorylation site a
protein binding site and also at some
interaction with some are binding
partners so the the trafficking AMPA
receptors into and out of synapses is a
very dynamic process it plays important
rule for synaptic plasticity and
learning on a memory so here it further
categorized under importance of AMPA
receptors in mediating synaptic
plasticity to be a specific LTP and Ltd
so as soon multiple evidence have shown
that the insertion or the incorporation
and AMPA receptors comparison of society
to the synaptic site can immediate LTP
or long-term potentiation while the
removal of mi receptors from the
synaptic side out away from the synapse
I'd committed Ltd so it's not surprising
that you know the the the disruption of
our acceptors our will leads to a lot of
human diseases indeed there are genetic
links have been found that the
disruption of AMPA receptors out this
regulation of the AMPA receptor function
have leads to a lot of neurological or
psychiatric diseases
for instance intellectual disability or
Tanakh disorder schizophrenia or
schizophrenia our zammis disease and
dementia so again due to the importance
of AMPA receptors play in synaptic
plasticity and overall brain function so
it's a very hard field of the study for
the scientific research so well the way
to study AMPA receptors is through our
imaging so here I'm showing you a
decision the neuronal culture those are
the hippocampus neurons here the cell
body is sending out beautiful neuronal
processes and the magenta shows a selfie
Oh to outline the neuronal processes
while those occur in puncta
understanding of the AMPA receptors with
the puncture a patent is a
characteristic of the am her center a
location as gene just briefly introduced
another chicken linking used to study
AMPA receptors - if the a super ecliptic
our flooring as Jean just mentioned for
his talk that one nice thing about the
Florent head is that when it's
trafficking in the vesicle facing the
acidic page the fluorescence is quenched
once the tag is delivered to the
membrane surface facing the neutral ph
outside the membrane
you're detected a dramatic increase in
terms of fluorescence intensity so in
such a way using this tag we were able
to
basically full of the dynamic or the
trafficking of the membrane population
of those AMPA receptors indeed a
previous work from RIT's lab have been
shown or he'll be using this have to
study immersive trafficking or membrane
incision in the desert and neuronal
culture as we can see here here is a
cell body of a sample our culture what
we do is we basically a photobleach and
eliminate all the fluorescence on the
surface of them on the memory surface
from the AMPA receptors then we used
turf my turf microscope to observe the
insertion or acceptors from the inside
of the cell what you can see here is as
thick a time series you can see those
bright puncta structure showing up
basically these are showing a group of
AMPA receptors in inserted into the
membrane service using this method we
were able to study a maricella
trafficking and the dynamics especially
for the membrane population in the
desert and neuronal culture so over the
years a couple a couple labs in in the
world including our lab are from the
Kuakini lab have been identified a very
separate complex that are playing
important role in invertebrate
trafficking and regulation and a
synaptic plasticity here I'm showing you
a very oversimplified version of the
AMPA receptor complex so basically those
are the protein protein binding partners
and the kindnesses that you know modify
or regulate and establish trafficking so
as I said so the research over the past
decade have dramatically other ones that
were understanding or am have separate
traffic and regulation especially at the
molecular level however a major missing
link in the field is we are still
unclear about how um how chapter traffic
and regulation are related to animal
behavior of how that emerges our traffic
and behave in people so where I don't
Rick's lab way back seven some years ago
we decide to address this question using
our two-photon yeah
energy so here this slide shows you the
basic strategy for how we are going to
image and how chapters in Babel so first
we are going to deliver at the September
chapters into lab animals using a method
called a neutral elaboration which I'll
explain a little bit more about this
technique and next slide and then the
second thing we need to do is to do a
craniotomy basically as to either
implant a window or finger score to so
that the microscope image through for to
observe amperes and the signals of
course the most important step is to
really image mr sebah dynamics in the
lab animals poses and a certain synaptic
plasticity conditions so this side shows
how our neutral occupation works so a
neutral electrician was pioneered by a
Chinese group about 15 years ago so what
this method how this mess will perform
is basically what you do is you inject a
dealing with interest into the later of
ventricle at a certain developmental age
of the embryo and then you use this type
of electrode to deliver electric force
which will pour the new interest into
the neuronal protein cells is learning
along the edge of the lateral ventricle
and then the neurons will be transfected
or be transduced with the interest and
there you put embryos back into the mom
and wait for the pups to be born so in
our study we are targeting on layer 2 3
pre-madonna neurons in the cerebral
cortex so we do like very roughly at a
15 so a nice thing with this method is
depending on the time you do the you do
the electroporation you can target
different layers of the of the parameter
cells so give you some kind of
flexibility flexibility in terms of
studying which lay of neurons so in our
case as I said we are interested in the
layer 2 3 population neurons we do a
usual occupation and a 15 and then we
wait for the pups to be born when the
rich young adulthood we do cranial
craniotomy then we give anymore about
two weeks to recover
from surgery with before we start our
two-photon imaging so another nice
feature about this measure is this is a
construct based method so we can include
multiple construct at the same time so
you in the following study i'm going to
present today we are a transfecting
subtag gray one make Takalua 2 and
morphology mark RDS red - so the
morphology market area - can not only
help us to identify the neuronal
processes it can also help us to serve
as a reference point when we do
intestine analysis which are briefly
touched on a later in the presentation
so first when we use this method we
first want to say okay how efficient can
we target those neurons and how a good
signal we can detect in terms of a
Florentin AMPA receptor expression so
here what we are doing is after a
neutral operation we're doing a acute
brain slice preparation at roughly p7 so
with no immuno standing after the acute
brain slice we just directly visualize
under the microscope as we can see
indeed we can target but this in the
population of neurons with a floor
integrant AMPA receptors and expression
of impressive attack is are pretty good
again next step is to do craniotomy so
for our case we choose the open score
trap method so you can either do open
skull or things called they have
advantages and this one both so the
reason we choose an open score is we're
expecting a relatively weaker expression
or integrant AMPA receptors as compared
to seven GFP which is created by opening
some 10 years years ago have been widely
used for two-photon imaging studies and
since the signal for the floor integrant
AMPA receptor will be weaker and then
the the open skull I'll give you a much
better chance in terms of detecting
await a signal so we choose an open
scope prep so basically what you do is
you cut off a piece of skull replace it
with a cow slip and then seal with
dental sealant so I'm here
showing a blow-up picture so as you can
see if you do a good job you can see it
is not much bleeding for the prep and
you can see very clear pattern of the
vasculature and also you know this is
how to say a relatively aggressive
surgery so we after this surgery we give
the animal about two to three weeks to
recover from from the surgery before we
start imaging under the microscope
so the first brain region we are decided
to start imaging my cyber dynamics is a
barrel cortex or the somatosensory
cortex so the reason is there is a
previous study have been found that
there is a very good one correlation
between individual Bisco and it's
corresponding barrel column inside the
barrel cortex so this one one a
correlation had some specificity to this
system with a very attractive system to
study synaptic plasticity so on top of
that we can use intrinsic optical or
signaling to map out individual barrel
columns as I show you here if you
deflect a one whisker you detect a
corresponding region in the brain if you
detect a different whisker you'll detect
a different region respond to the
whisker deflection so let let me explain
to you how or what we are measuring for
the intrinsic intrinsic optical
signaling so here what we're marrying is
we're measuring the light deflection of
the brain surface what happens is if you
deflect a specific whisker the neurons
in is corresponding brain region will be
activated then the local oxygen
consumption will go up so then comes a
consequence of that is you have a
increased concentration for dioxide
Hammond hemoglobin so then under
wavelengths of 630 nanometers the more
deoxyhemoglobin you have the less light
will bounce off the bring surface so in
other word if you deflect the activate
the bring area will go stuck and then
recover once the blood flow comes in and
repopulate
I just really oxygenate the deoxy
hemoglobin so using this method we were
able to
map out individual barrel columns and
then based on the position of the
individual column and the pattern of the
vasculature we were able to zoom in to a
specific whisker an image the same
neuronal processes again and again so
for the following study i'm going to
present to you the study was performed
in unauthorized animals and also we are
deflecting one whisker at a time and all
the whiskers have been kept and intact
so here I'm showing you a dis tack of
the in vivo imaging of the aseptically
one we were able to acquire through our
customers to fold a microscope through
the cranial window so here I'm showing
you we are imaging from the top of the
brain surface and going inside and here
I basically give your idea how deep we
are in in terms of relative to the
harboring surface and the the green
signal is from the Sapkal a 1 and the
magenta signal is from the PS red 2 as
you can see as we go deeper we can
detect both decent signal from both
channels and as we go deeper we can see
all the neuronal processes are converge
to the cell body and this is about 250
some microns deep into the brain surface
and here I'm showing a 3d rendering of
the previous existing I just showed you
we can detect a cell body pretty well I
was a signal from both channels and
sending a beautiful neuronal processes
on to the top layer of the brain surface
and in the top layer indeed we can
detect those green puncta like structure
which are the cell type and her
receptors and another nice thing as I
just mentioned those cell bodies about
250 to 300 microns deep into the brain
surface which are exactly a layer to
three neurons should look should locate
which it's our target population of
neurons so once we were able to detect a
good signal in vivo for my receptors and
next thing we want to see okay how
wearable is AMPA receptor
fashion uh if you do new manipulation or
whatsoever so here I'm showing you for
this mice we just go back to the same
barrel or to the same barrel column and
omit the same internal processes again
again for about a month so with no
sensory stimulation or or any kind of
manipulation as we can see indeed over
the course of one month we were able to
detect very stable expression in terms
of the fluorine camel receptors and also
for the District two so another
interesting phenomenon we note notice
from this experiment is that the
relative synaptic strength judged by the
intensity of the flooring of our sectors
it's also kept relatively stable during
this period of time but as you can see
that you know for this spot the this
very strong imperishable signal in the
beginning this this this one is always
being the strongest in terms of a
perceptor intensity well for this one
there's a relatively less and receptors
and has been kept stable and during this
one was period so we think there is
intrinsic mechanism to keep the relative
synaptic strengths during this period of
time because the half-life of those
intercepts about 40 hours so those
receptors or the intensity we see here
at the end of the month it's totally
different from what's we detect in the
beginning so there must be some kind of
mechanism to cap or recognize the
initial synaptic strength so that keep
the relative synaptic currents stable
during this long period of time so once
we acquire this nice images the next big
step is to do image analysis actually I
think for for anybody who is interested
or known some basic knowledge about
imaging is in a world of a big step or
well the heavy step is to do image
analysis so luckily for us another
talented postdoc
of is Debbie Linden which is also at
Hopkins that float down from us so we
were just having a casual talk to during
launch we're seeing okay we are
you know running into this and nice
problem we have we can accumulate a big
set of data we are sitting there for us
to analyze so a thing with the software
for the analysis there are couple
software's out there and it works okay
for some immunostaining or digital
culture for email imaging actually as of
today there's no automatic software or
automatic program can do the job for you
so basically he is also very interested
in the in the problem he's also doing
something in vivo imaging and when we
talk about we decide to do a custom
design software is a semi automatic
custom it's a semi automatic software
the human beings I still need to I do a
lot of the work so I'll briefly walk you
through how this software works so
basically once you input those images
into the software what we do the human
beings need to do is to click the tip of
the spine basically tell the software ok
here I recognize this is a spine then
the software will automatically find the
connection point between the spine and
the dendritic shaft then once this
connection established three regional
interest will be defined by the software
one region is the spine region interest
this is about the square box another
region is a background originally
interest basically is in the
neighborhood and with to define to
detect the background intensity so
another region is called a chef the
regional interest basically it's a
connection point between the spine and
the shaft about five microns away from
the connection point so once this 3
meter is defined this region will be
automatically applied to both channels
so there are a couple of things we can
analyze or we can look at for for the
for the images first is a spine size so
the spine size is defined as such so you
calculate the intensity of the pixel in
the spy region interest and thus
abstract the intensity of the pixel in
the background rate of interest and then
my eyes against intensity in the shaft
radio interest we define as spy
instructor in intensity which is a
pregnancy or the estimate of the spine
size of course more interestingly and
unique for our imaging study is we are
able to look at intensity of the surface
our my receptors so we there are two
parameters we can look at first it was a
spy service my receptors and now on is a
shaft of surface a my receptors I'll
just walk you through the definition of
the surface and receptors so is the
total incident intensity in the circle a
one channel in this by region interest
subtract the background region interest
the total intensity and then normalize
against a dendritic shaft which will be
defined at the spine surface school
event intensity it's an indication of
the intensity of my receptors on a
spying surface so when we take a close
look of the animals we lacked rate we
were able to find that we were able to
detect very beautiful signals at the
table spine another interesting
phenomena we find is that within a
couple of microns from each other we can
detect with dramatic differences in
terms of their spine surface receptors
for this one we get a lot of other
receptors in the spine surface well for
this one we don't have much at all
so we speculate that for this type of
spine
most likely represent the population
with spines have active synapses why for
this population spine replaced the
spines with silent synapses
I have to admit that in our images we
were able to detect such a phenomena but
especially adult animals those silent
spans are very rare so for the focus
study we are for the following study we
are focusing on this type of spine
basically have some type of anti
receptor to studies in our study and
then look at their dynamics after
whisker stimulation so if we look at the
whole spine population we find that that
is a it is a wide distribution in terms
of the spine surface and herself
as shown here and also interestingly we
find that and the basal conditions there
is a very good correlation between the
spine size or the approximate size spine
structure intensity and the spine
surface intensity so indeed the previous
previous studies have been using the the
sides of the spine as a estimate of how
much am her scepters is on the spine
surface basically our study cannibal how
does the repeat they're finding or
consistent with the assumption while
I'll tell you a little later in terms of
changes in those two there are
differences in our study so as I briefly
introduce to you that in the first urban
region we decide to study AMPA receptors
is a barrel cortex so what we are doing
here we want to see okay if we want to
if we apply a rigorous a very strong
whisker stimuli what will happen to the
land surface receptors so what we are
doing is we're doing a 10 Hertz whine
our constant whisker stimulation what we
do is we take images before we start the
whisker stimulation then we start
whisker stimulation then we take it
immediately after the whisker
stimulation and in two hours three hours
after whisker stimulation so as shown
here if we look at this spine for
instance we detect some type of anti
receptors in the surface of the spine
after whisker stimulation which it had a
traumatic increase in the amount or that
based on the intensity of the surface
span Amhara scepters this increase has
been kept stable for at least three
hours while in the control group with no
whisker stimulation as we can say for
this by instance the amount of surface
AMPA receptors don't change too much so
here is a quantification of all the
spines we imaged so overall we image
about 600 some spines in the skin
a group and 500 song spans in the
control group so here if we look at the
change of the spine size before and
after whisker stimulation we don't
detect much change there is no
difference between the stimuli group and
the control group however if we look at
the overall spine population what we
find is there is a dramatic increase in
the spine surface and how it scepters as
it's quantified here there about a 30%
increase and also there is increase in
the shaft surface and the receptors is
also about increased about 30% as I said
so this three figures gives you idea
when we look at the span population as a
whole how does how does those spine
surface umpires are the changes so how
so but what doesn't mean in in great
detail exactly so it doesn't mean you
know every spine change a little bit or
there's only a small population spines
change and also does it mean because you
know in in the neurons every neuron has
a couple graduate branches we can image
right so it doesn't mean you know
different dendritic branches change the
same after whisker stimulation or
they're somewhat different right and
also for all this three parameters as I
briefly introduced in terms of the
changes are those correlated or what are
the relationships between those changes
so those are those have questions we dig
a little deeper into the data and I'll
show you the result so when we look at
the spines individually what we find is
there's only about 30% of the spine show
a change in the spine surface AMPA
receptors after whisker stimulation the
majority of spines don't don't show a
change this is also true when we look at
a dating graphic level so for this
figure what we are doing here is for one
thing graphic second we are averaging
one particular dendritic segment and
then assign a number then we compare
that number before and after whisker
stimulation so for the stimuli group we
image about 50/50 tooth into attic
segment while we found is only about 11
of them about 20%
or the things I'll show increase in
their spine surface and her scepters
after whisker stimulation so this tells
us those changes in the spine surface
and her receptors is not uniform across
the bearer field it's not uniform across
even the dendritic segments so there are
only a subpopulation sponge and a
subpopulation with dendritic shaft that
respond to the whisker stimulation and
also as I said what are the
relationships in terms of looking at the
changes or those three parameters so
here I'm showing you the correlation at
one our point of the whisker simulation
between the change of spine size and the
change of surface and receptors again as
compared to the baseline there is also a
decent correlation between the changes
of those two however if we look
carefully we find that the average line
is significantly above the y equal x
line
what doesn't mean is although there is a
good correlation between the changes for
these two parameters but it seems like
when we look at individual spine the
spine surface AMPA receptors always
change more as compared to the change to
spine size or in other word after
whisker stimulation we might detect a
change in the density of the spine
surface and receptors here shows you
that there is a very good collision
between the changes in the shaft surface
and receptors and the spine surface
armor receptors those two parameters are
very well correlated with each other
while on the other hand there's no
correlation detected between the change
in spine size and the change in the
shaft or surface receptors so the
take-home message from this is that the
change in the spine surface AMPA
receptors it's very well correlated with
the change of spawn size and also with
the change of shape the surface and the
receptors
however there are the differences also
between those three parameters and for
this one I'll tell you a little later
what are the differences in terms of
changes after whisker stimulation so the
next thing we want to do is what are the
mechanisms right so we want to
here we won't briefly know a little bit
more about the mechanism about this
phenomenon after whisk assimilation
there is increase in the spine surface
AMPA receptors what are the possible
mechanisms while the usual suspect is MD
receptors because Emory and the receptor
dependent LTP is a majority with a metre
type of LTP people have been studying so
we take an educated guess that let's
first ask whether this phenomenon is an
d receptor dependent so what we are
doing here we apply a drug a CPP which
is an MD receptor antagonist okay
this drug can easily across the
blood-brain barrier so what we are doing
here we are doing exactly the same
procedure as the whisker stimulation and
the only difference is here we are we
are applying a CPP to those animals
before we start whisker stimulation as
indicated here in the in the
representative images and also in the
quantification in the quantification at
the bottom the application of the CPP
completely block the whisker deflection
induced increase in terms of surface
receptors so if anything there is a
trend toward dickweeds although
statistically is not significant and
also it blocks the the changes caused by
the whisker stimulation for the entire
surface and by receptors so basically
what this figure tells you that indeed
this persist in this process is MD
receptor dependent event so as I have
told you in the introduction so a
another characteristics of LTP or Ltd is
its long-lasting right in the in
bringing slice recording it can last for
about an hour or two depend on how long
you can hold the cell so we took
advantage of the imaging approach and
then we follow the AMPA receptors for
even longer or here I'm showing you for
48 48 hour time points assume here the
again there's no difference in terms of
the spine size change our before and
after whisker stimulation for a short
term or long term for the
in the span surface and hair samples
what we find is the increase of spine
surface receptors after Bisco
stimulation is relatively long-lasting
it can still have a traumatic difference
at $40
TenPoint however interestingly the
change in the shaft surface and my
receptors comes back to about 6% at 6
hours and then returned to about the
return to the level of the control at 48
hour a time point so that's what we are
seeing here because here we don't have
the single molecule resolution yet so we
don't know exactly what's happening in
terms of a single molecule but what we
speculate is that in the insertion or
AMPA receptors into the memory surface
and the incorporation of the of the AMPA
receptors from the memory surface into
the spine are two related but also
distinct processes and the synaptic
plasticity conditions so here is the
brief summary of what how told you first
we find that it's a acute whisker
stimulation can lead to a rapid increase
in the spine surface AMPA receptors but
only in a summer population with
dendritic spines and a summer population
or dendritic shaft and also I have shown
you that this increase caused by a
whisker stimulation is the MD receptor
dependent process and also is relatively
long lasting so as I said as compared to
previous imaging studies we add a new
layer of plasticity to the study so
previously people just using the salon
GFP to image spine dynamics and here on
top of spine dynamics we can also
measure the relative synaptic strengths
by monitoring the relative intensity on
surface of the spine so basically our
approach opens up a totally new way of
imaging a synaptic plasticity so next
I'll just briefly tell you
couple interesting ongoing project and
what I'm going to do for my new lab so
as I said the Prima the the the study
are just present to you were done in a
NASA Tyson animals and we are using the
artificial and a very strong whisker
stimulation and paradigm so ok it's so
nice and we were able to observe those
unhappy dynamics in vivo for the first
time but really what doesn't mean we
don't really know because this is a very
strong of their vigorous whisker
stimulation the animal might never
experience in their whole life so the
next we want to understand a little bit
deeper or in other way how this AMPA
receptor behave and physiological
conditions or how does a mother behave
in a week behaving animals because when
animal is an anesthesia is you know
somewhat different in terms of their you
know every parameter right so we
observed the thing in Anna's understand
animals how does that will will that
transfer into a week bohemian animals we
don't know yet so that's why we want to
further study the am how separate
dynamics are purely learning in a week
beginning animals so in collaboration
with a certain professor Dan O'Connor at
Hopkins we develop this go/no-go a task
for the animal to to learn or acquire
and an image while the animal is a weak
and performing the task so what we do
here is we restrict the water supply to
the animal for about a week so the
animal is thirsty during this period of
time so it has a motivation to search
for water reward then after a week of
water restriction we put anymore under
the microscope so then we do a to a
leaking period what we do here is there
is a metal pour within the region
distance from the top of the mice so if
there any more leaks then the metaphor
would deliver a drop of water that
we'll get the water reward so then we do
two leaking sessions then what we do is
we do a record at this discrimination
so then what the animal has to learn is
once it's received a whisk a deflection
signal is supposed to look for water
reward if there is no whisk whisk a
deflection signal delivered even if the
animal leaks there will be no water
reward so basically the animal needs to
acquire or get the sense that you have
to receive the whiskers African signal
before you leave or get the water reward
so on the right I'm showing you a
successful trial for the animal to get
that water reward as you can see there
is a glass pipette hanging in here and
whisker is poking into this glass
pipette what you'll see in the following
video
this glass I've had will wiggle first
then the anymote it get that signal then
it will leak for the water reward so
here comes the deflection then the
animal lick for the water reward so if
there's no deflection you mean the
animal leaks there will be no water
reward so of course in the beginning the
anymore and not anymore does not know
what is supposed to do so it's basically
guessing or because it has the
motivation to search for water reward
it's leaking most of the time but you
know half the time it's right half time
is wrong so the performance is about 50%
but after five to seven days a trial you
can see the performance of the animal in
terms with task is getting much better
jump to like 70% and you can get this
steady performance for a relatively long
period of time an interesting thing is
okay once after about two weeks of
training we think okay this animal has
acquired successfully acquired this task
we just stopped the stream what we do we
put animal back into the homepage we
still restrict the water supply so that
animals still thirsty and then a week
later we put any more back and
microscope we find that the anymore
still remembers well about the task
another week later it still remembers
another week later it still remembers so
basically what this s is shows you is
that this is a very good paradigm not
only to access how well to enema can
acquire the task is also a verbal
paradigm to access how well to animal
can remember the task so what we are do
now we are imaging those animals in
terms a and those are the electric
created animals with the floor Integra
AMPA receptors so we are imaging AMPA
receptors immediately after each and
every training session so we have
acquired a rich set of data a sitting
there or in the process of analyzing we
want to see exactly in a weak behaving
animals under this learning paradigm how
does a Marcel traffic and behave during
this learning and memory tasks so
another direction I want to go is as I
said we just briefly addressed what is a
magnet right is you can say okay it's
easy guess it's MD receptor dependent so
what what's a date for the mechanism so
in order to address that question so a
direction going to go is it's a
collaboration with dr. ginger who was
previously at hardness now recently
moved to UCSD she developed a serious
kind of sensors that can monitor the
kinase activity so I just to this
audience I don't have to see too much I
just briefly introduce you one type is
sensors it's fret based sensors so if
it's two floor falls is far away there's
no fret energy transfer if under if
after phosphorylation and a confirmation
change those two floor four is close to
each other then you there will be a
threat transfer you shine light one for
for your detect the fret signal so here
I'm showing you the experiment from the
pKa kind of sensor what we are doing
here this is the desert internal culture
this is acute bring slice with a drug
that can activate the PK signal we can
see
after treatment the drug with a dramatic
increase in terms of fret signal
basically this shows you indeed this by
sensor works very well in the social
internal culture and a cue to prune
slices do they work in bebo
so we also briefly test how well those
sensors works in Babel as shown here
those are again transparent URLs and
here's the signal from the donor here's
a signal from the acceptor and we using
another paradigm this epinephrine
injection can also lead to an increase
in the peak a kinase activity that is
increase indeed in terms of proof of
principle those thread sensors can be
used and the in vivo conditions and
another thing we are in the process of
doing that is also another type of about
sensors it's the single color biosensors
which can give us a capacity to to
monitor kinase activity or single
enhancer activity a multiple a signaling
pathway activity I've shown here those
single caliber sensors also works well
as shown here you see for scaling can
needs to increase for the applications
were reading F can lead to increase in
the earth sensor and also briefly in the
different neuronal culture we're showing
that for screen is specific to activity
key to activate the PD kindness and the
database you can active both so all
right here's a summary so in in the
future we want to investigate a parasail
dynamics and v logical manipulation
conditions and we were in the process of
doing enriched environment and also
whisker trimming and such and also to
address the detailed molecular mechanism
we're going to uses a fret sensor or the
single color balancer in in in
combination with the Interceptor imaging
trying to to tease out the D to the
molecule of methanol underlying synaptic
plasticity and also we can use this
method really to better understand our
understanding our pathology or neurotic
or disorders such as
disease so first and foremost I want to
thank Rick signior for his tremendous
support and I thank all the members and
collaborators and thank you for your
attention
Thanks
[Applause]